this whole topic when it comes to gender
i
either it's a fad and it's going to go
away quickly because people realize how
ridiculous it is and i don't know if
we're going in that direction right now
because we have medical professionals
saying that there's no difference
between a man and a woman if there's no
difference between a man and woman why
why take hormones medical professionals
yeah yeah medical i put that in some
quotation marks crazy that these people
have gone to school for 12 years they
have job titles that we've never heard
of before like gender assigned blah blah
blah they're bought and sold that's why
they're bought and sold exactly but
these are people that are who's whose
opinions are respected because they're
supposed to be educated telling people
that there's no such there's no
difference between men and women yet
they're prescribing hormones that's a
huge contradiction they don't even like
people aren't even willing to look at
the contradictions in these ideals like
the same people who believe in in
women's rights will say that there's no
such thing as a woman or they can't even
define what a woman is those are huge
contradictions